Elon Musk أول Twitter يتشكل
ليكون تجربة رائعة ، وقد حصلنا هذا الأسبوع
على معاينة لما
ستبدو عليه المواجهة القانونية لشهر أكتوبر
كخبر سار لإيلون يمكن لفريقه استخدام
معلومات من
المُبلغ عن المخالفات على Twitter في قضيته والأخبار السيئة
للقاضي  رفض طلبًا لنقل
موعد المحاكمة وكشف Twitter عن بعض
الرسائل النصية اللافتة للنظر من Elon Musk ،
لذا هنا لكسر ما يعنيه الأمر
كلير دافي كلير من CNN ، مرحبًا ،
كانت هذه الجلسة بمثابة معاينة
لما يجب أن نتوقعه مباشرة من
في أكتوبر / تشرين الأول ، أخبرنا ما إذا كانت هناك
أي مفاجآت ،
نعم أنت تعرف أنني لا أعرف أن
هناك أي مفاجآت بالضرورة ، لكننا
نحصل على فكرة أفضل
عما سوف يجادل فيه كل طرف عن
أنواع الأدلة التي يجمعونها
خلال هذه العملية وكيف
سيستخدمون كل ما تعرفه ، من
الواضح أن فريق المسك يركز على
مشكلة الروبوت هذه ، وهو يدعي أن هناك المزيد من الروبوتات على
Twitter أكثر من Twitter يكشف أن فريقه
يركز أيضًا  الغناء في
حسابهم mdow رقم المستخدم النشط اليومي الذي يمكن تحقيق الدخل منه
والذي يستخدمونه للإبلاغ عن عدد
المستخدمين على النظام الأساسي الذي يجادلون فيه
بأن هذا ليس مقياسًا جيدًا
يعرف Twitter أنه ليس مقياسًا جيدًا
وأنه يستخدم داخليًا مقاييس أخرى
و  حتى تعلم أننا نتفهم
كيف تتشكل هذه الحجة ،
وما أنواع الأدلة
التي سيستخدمونها في المحاكمة في أكتوبر
، فلنتحدث عن الرسائل النصية
بعد وقت قصير من إعلان Elon Musk
أنه كان يشتري Twitter ،  لقد كان قلقًا من
أن روسيا يمكن أن تصعد حربها مع
أوكرانيا إلى أجزاء أخرى من العالم ،
ولذا في نص علمناه للتو
أنه أرسل رسالة نصية لمصرفيه قائلاً: دعونا
نبطئ بضعة أيام فقط من خطاب بوتين
غدًا مهم للغاية أنه فاز ''  ليس من
المنطقي شراء Twitter إذا كنا
متجهين إلى الحرب العالمية الثالثة ، لذا فإن
الرسالة النصية بالتأكيد لا تتعلق بالروبوتات
الصحيحة وهذا هو السبب الذي جعل Elon Musk
قد قال إنه يريد الانسحاب
من الصفقة.  تؤكد رسالة xt نوعًا ما
على وجهة نظر Twitter بأن المسك كان
يستخدم مشكلة الروبوت كذريعة
للابتعاد عن هذه الصفقة ،
سيقول Twitter
بالتأكيد أنك تعرف أن Twitter سيستخدم
هذه الرسالة النصية وأي دليل آخر على
أنه يمكنه  تجد مثل ذلك لإثبات أن
Elon لم يكن مهتمًا بالفعل
بالروبوتات عندما قرر إنهاء هذه الصفقة
لأنه كان قلقًا بشأن الاقتصاد
أو الوضع الجيوسياسي ، ولن يكون أي منهما
أسبابًا مشروعة
للابتعاد عن صفقة
كهذه وبدلاً من ذلك ،  من طرح مشكلة الروبوت
كذريعة للانسحاب من هذه
الصفقة ، وهو نفس السبب الذي يجعلك
تتخيل أنهم يطرحون أسئلة
على أصدقاء Elon Musk الأثرياء والمصرفيين الذين
تعرفهم أنهم سيرغبون في معرفة ما إذا
كان يتحدث  حول مشكلة الروبوت في وقت مبكر
بعد توقيعه على هذه الصفقة ، حيث كانوا
يطرحون أسئلة حول مشكلة الروبوت
التي من شأنها أن تتطلب منه الذهاب إلى
Twitter لطرح هذه الأنواع من الأسئلة
التي تعرف أن Twitter سيرغب في محاولة ذلك
إثبات أن مشكلة الروبوت التي تعرفها هي في
الحقيقة مجرد عذر لـ Elon
وأنها ليست مصدر قلق مشروع حقًا